foreign
commenting on the release of the legal
assessment
of the Windsor framework the ERG
chairman Mark Francois said
I'd like to thank
I'd like to thank the Star Chamber
chaired by sabil cash MP and ably
supported by Martin Howe Casey Barnabas
Reynolds and David Jones MP for their
diligent and thorough examination of the
legal implications of the Windsor
framework
the star Chambers principal findings are
that EU law will still be Supreme in
Northern Ireland
the rights of its people under the 1800
active Union are not restored
the Green Lane is not really a Green
Lane at all
the storm on break is practically
useless and the framework itself has no
exit other than through a highly complex
legal process that is a very brief
summary of the findings of the style
chamber you should hopefully all have a
copy of the report with a press release
and there's a nice diagram on the back
that shows you how the storm won't break
in theory at least is meant to work I
hope that's a quick summary I can take
four or five quick questions so sorry
let's uh let's start here
yeah do you accept
more important
no I don't accept that at all and and
the reasons why that is not correct are
set out in the report but I would
encourage you to read it so who's there
yes cop will you be voting against the
proposals therefore and how many ERG
colleagues of yours do you expect will
fall asleep right on that the dup have
made their position very plain they're
going to vote against we to some degree
have been critical of the government for
not allowing people enough time to
digest everything so for instance the
statutory instrument and the explanatory
notes only came out yesterday
so we don't want to be hoist by our own
so we've just made this public now it is
available on the internet and the email
address at lawyers for Britain is on
your press release if you could
promulgate that we would be grateful so
that other members of parliament can
read this is by no means just for the
ERG we'd like all members of parliament
ideally to read this before the vote
tomorrow so they know exactly what
they're voting on
and we'd like members of the public and
particularly people in Northern Ireland
to have an opportunity to read this
report so that they understand what is
at stake
because we need to allow people time to
digest this the ERG will meet be meeting
again tomorrow in this room at the same
time once people have had an opportunity
to digest all this documentation and
some of it is pretty heavy legalese but
I've tried to summarize it for you we as
a group will discuss what attitude if I
need to take and we'll be having that
meeting just before PM's keys and we're
meeting at half past 10. and then
immediately before the vote so that is
when we as a group will decide what
we're going to do when to be fed of
people have had a chance to plow through
some fairly complex documentation so can
we just take from that that you may
actually you may have should have stayed
you may look well the group hasn't taken
the decision yet and ultimately this has
always been our way it'll be down to
every individual colleague in the group
so I'm not going to preempt that
decision for all the reasons I've just
given you but now can I just make a
point about the Stormont the so-called
storm on break
you've got a diagram on the back let me
see if I can summarize this for you very
quickly
one it only applies if Stormont is up
and running
say for instance Shin Fein for any
reason were to just were to collapse the
assembly the break would no longer apply
secondly it's very limited in its scope
it applies to Goods
but not to stay paid vat the majority of
the Customs code so-called trade defense
measures and the electricity Market
so it's only applicable in narrow
circumstances
three
the EU law being proposed against which
the break could be theoretically
deployed has to have a significant
impact on everyday life in Northern
Ireland in a way which is liable to
persist
also it can only be exercised in
exceptional circumstances
but the Secretary of State for Northern
Ireland
can decide not to accept the break being
used in exceptional circumstances
it has to be discussed in the UK EU
joint committee as a matter of urgency
where the UK can decide not to implement
the bro
even if they do decide to implement the
break via the Joint Committee
the EU can then still object to that
to that and the matter is then referred
to arbitration
where the UK could lose
so that is clearly not a veto a veto
means you want to do something and I can
stop you this is not a veto which is how
it has been characterized for the past
three weeks
even if after all of that
you win at arbitration
and there's no guarantee you will
the EU can then Implement remedial
measures I.E they can retaliate
and then lastly
after all of that if you've had the
temerity to pull the break
the UK via the Joint Committee then has
to produce the results of an urgent
review as to why they felt the break had
to be used in the first place
that is the Stormont break
sorry I'm going to leave that to others
to judge but I want people to read this
document which explains all of this in
detail but that is why having explained
it to you I hope having walked you
through it and thank you for your
patience just a second and thank you for
your patience because that is why
we have said that the break is
practically useless against it let's
have wait till we've got our meeting
tomorrow given what you said is there
any way you could not vote against
it let's wait to what happens tomorrow
thank you very much indeed for your
attention then Jenna it's all I hope the
press release helped you it's all on the
internet please promulgate it as widely
as you can thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
um
says